jim cantore from the weather channel
back on the program Jim good morning
where are you right now damn good
morning it's been a while my friend fort
pierce florida so we're down in d what
they call the treasure coast of florida
okay why are you there well yesterday
the forecast for 4am was to have 125
mile per hour winds over the top of us
and we moved in a position to you know
the drill you've been at were you going
to put your truck where is it going to
be best protected from the weather where
can we actually get a signal out through
the worst of the storm so logistics
pretty much move this to this spot
yesterday we had to get up barrier
island we were at melbourne beach right
right on the beach with no protection so
we moved down here and the forecast
thank goodness did not verify we pretty
much got half that in terms of the wind
speed 60 70 miles an hour so it's weird
though that you're your bosses at the
weather channel are going to send you to
what they think would be the worst areas
that's correct exactly right that's love
is it well okay but how does just go
over with the family like I know you've
been doing this for over 30 years but
you you know you're headed into harm's
way I mean how does being a race car
driver go over the sandwich you driving
around making left turns 200 mile an
hour how does you know being a soldier
go with the family when you're over
there take an enemy fire or whatever the
heck else they're doing you know it's
the job it's it's what I do it's what we
do and I take the mission and then brace
it and do it the best I can what's the
biggest complaint you have when you do
this in your in harm's way and you're
telling people about this what bothers
you the most about you know the people's
reaction to your reports a lot of times
people I think kind of make it they've
April try and play meteorologists and
that you know like for example for the
first time in my life actually I saw the
director of the Hurricane Center just
come on about two hours ago and
essentially plea p
call that are in the storm surge warning
to leave because he's very very
concerned about people going underwater
in parts of Georgia northern Florida and
South Carolina I've never seen that um
from from a director so that was pretty
pretty incredible I know this man I know
I can speak to his character dr. Rick
nap and he you know really a heartfelt
plea to get to get people out of harm's
way so the answer your question is when
people's kind of ignore you know what
we're asking them to do I mean if you
live on the coast you got to realize you
put yourself in harm's way and prepare
yourself a plan you know where are you
going to go you go stay with relatives
you go to an inland hotel it just kind
of make it a drill a part of your life
and what people don't do that it does
kind of as they say frost my cake but
you're also when you look at trying to
tell people about this you give us an
idea of the areas that you think are
going to be in real danger here in the
next 12 hours hi I mean first of all
there's always uncertainty you know
yesterday at this time if you had asked
me we were making a decision to move me
off the barrier island because we just
thought with the pace place that we had
to stay house it wasn't boarded up in
weekly built and being that close to the
beach where we could actually have the
water coming over the top of the dunes
you know what maybe it's not really
because I do this may here we didn't
want to be a part of the story so we
made a decision to come down here to
Fort Pierce which logistically set us up
in a much better position to broadcast
during the hurricane I mean we asked
people to leave we asked them to
evacuate and you know this to me I've
always kind of taken the approach you
know the least I could do is take these
people through it I could show him what
why they left and show them how bad it
was now fortunately the storm stayed
another 30 miles offshore we had some
weird things going on with the core of
the hurricane and that did not allow
those 120 mile per hour winds to make
their way on shore that's a very good
thing jim cantore from Weather Channel
joining a Stan Patrick show here's
another thing that I always here
whenever there is a potential storm not
not like this or hurricane but then you
know that storm and it's going to be a
bad storm and then it never happens it
feels like that's when people look at
the local weather and say it just feels
like we're
we're going to scare people to watch the
local weather do you hear that complaint
I know hundreds of meteorologists out
there and I can't think of one of them
that purposely walks on the air to try
to scare people we take the forecast to
the best of our ability and try to
interpret it to people so that they can
stay safe for themselves in their
families that's really the motifs and so
you know that said sometimes the
forecast doesn't pan out perfectly but
I'm going to tell you this I'd rather be
yelled at because the forecast didn't
verify that way and not have something
happen where I didn't prepare some of
that means that you really not done your
job when's the last time you really
thought you were in some serious trouble
you know what I mean we've always one of
the things about logistics is you always
kind of have an escape route you know do
we have a sturdy building are we in the
surf zone I think with Katrina you know
we were a little misled as to how high
we were above sea level and that's why
we lost four vehicles that that was a
little unnerving not not so much for me
because I understand storm since I know
water comes up in hurricanes but for a
lot of my colleagues my photographer you
know audio folks producers who don't
know the meteorology don't understand
why is the water coming up why are we
all of a sudden the part of the Gulf of
Mexico so that's uh you know those kind
of things bother me but you know I think
really it's on my shoulders to make sure
my crew safe out here that's part of my
job in addition to communicating the
weather how much you bench in these days
dan I prepared for this question um i'm
up to a hundred pounds now dude and i'm
so excited about I gym on come on I you
got ad Hockey League guns going there
Jim don't be modest come on I'm not I'm
not a super venture I've already we've
had this discussion you know I'm a 225
guy bump it up to three times that's
where I max out at and I'm good with
that I'm really good without I'm
comfortable with that tyranny
has anybody ever made a shirt if if you
see this man in your town get out and we
just have a picture I heard how about
all the memes have you see have you gone
on facebook and Mel twitter i knows me
if cantore comes to tell us the one
cantore is like uh getting a divorce and
your ex-wife takes every when cantore
shows up it's like getting a divorce
your ex-wife takes everything you know
that kind of stuff pretty creative ain't
spirited mean-spirited that if you got
to do in if you see him in town get out
jim cantore be safe there how long does
this watch is should we be aware of this
the whole weekend with this hurricane as
much of the fact that that that Florida
has done pretty well with this in terms
of escaping the core of the hurricane
what is unavoidable now Dan is kind of
what i call part two of this tonight and
tomorrow morning in the storm search
we're really worried about very very
high water rises in southern Georgia the
beautiful golden isles of georgia you
probably see island that new place I
mean water is going to come up big time
there to the likings that people have
never seen before so even with a storm
it's weakening or may stay left or right
attract depending on what's happening
with the core it's already set up to
happen so I'm worried that people are
looking at this from oh it's weaker oh
it didn't really get Florida the big
wins just what it's it's it's going to
give the storm surge component so
Northeast Florida Georgia and really
even into Charleston I think we're at
risk of that and we may even get to 10
to 12 to 18 inches of rain in interior
south of north carolina so we're about
I'd say a third of the way through this
well good to have you on as always and
as always be safe brother thank you Jim
that's a jim cantore Weather Channel's
been there over 30 years a certified
broadcast meteorologist like there's no
joke there I don't know the difference
between being a meteorologist and he's
certified broadcast meteorologist yes he
do you think that's like a point of
contention or like traffic when they're
at the convention you're just a
meteorologist and certified bro yeah
certified this yeah yeah
where's your certification the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience